well this is really a story that just
captured the world's attention the Ocean
Gate submersible that imploded while it
was going to actually see the Titanic a
Las Vegas Father and Son turned down
their spots though they could have
actually been on that vessel eight news
now reporter Brian will spoke to them
tells us why they chose not to go on
that sub
we do a lot of really cool and crazy
experiences we've we've done things like
ziplining we've gone into hot air
balloons I'm a helicopter pilot Jay
Bloom and his son Sean were looking for
their next adventure Stockton brought
him the opportunity and he wanted to do
this mainly for me because he knew what
a big fan of the Titanic I was and he
was excited to do it too you know
Stockton flew into Vegas to come talk to
me in March and we met at uh Luxor he
actually walked me through the Titanic
Exhibition at Luxor and then we sat in
the food court and and talked after
talking and initially declining the
offer to go on the sub they received
this text from Stockton Rush offering
for him and his son to go on the sub for
two hundred thousand dollars less my
biggest problem with this whole thing
and the reason we ultimately ended up
not going was with the submarine itself
I was worried about the structural
Integrity of the submarine I was worried
about the way the submarine was
controlled that decision was the one
that ultimately saved their lives and
the fourth picture was the father and
son and I would look at that and I would
just think but for one decision uh that
would be our picture and it's been kind
of a surreal experience for us too you
know knowing that that could have been
us on that submarine as for all the
attention they're getting this attention
is making us realize how real the
situation is the fact that that father
and son on that submarine would have
been us if you know we didn't say no to
Stockton that that would have been us if
the chance came again to go see the
Titanic they would depending on who it
was with reporting in Las Vegas Brian
will eight news now